this is the heated moment that led up to
the uh incident um which we will
describe for you and offer some opinions
from the legal lander which uh legal
andrew legal angle which andrew will be
great at uh providing some feedback on
and i want to talk about it from the
perspective of um divorce and my
experience dealing with family law and a
lot of the guys that i deal with because
i've coached uh
hundreds of dudes now that are high net
worth individuals dealing with conflict
and high conflict divorce a lot of
acrimony and fighting back and forth
when the kids get picked up on sort of
stuff and i got some thoughts on that
too so
um you you've probably researched this
way better than i have so do you want to
like tell the story and what happened
here you know this particular incident
yeah sure and and once again guys
there's lots of videos out there i've
done some on my channel a legal mindset
there's many other lawyers that have
gone out there and analyzed this in
terms of the self-defense analysis in
terms of at the end of the day once the
shoot happens was this a good shoot or
not a good shoot i'm not gonna go into
depth on that but i'll just give a very
thirty thousand foot overview
so there's two gentlemen there's uh kyle
carreth who's the guy or karat you know
people say that different i'll just say
kyle right so kyle is the guy with the
gun right that's the sky on the left
here yes the guy on the left is kyle
he's the one holding the gun we think
it's a 22 caliber based on the fact that
when it fires it is very very silent um
the guy in the teal shirt who's a bit
larger his name is chad that's his
actual name i'm not calling him a chad
he uh he's the chad though
yeah he is chad he was the chad actually
but yeah yes was r.i.p
um he was the guy who was going nipple
to nipple as i say there to the guy's
chest nipple to nipple it's more like
nipple to shoulder in this
it's the height difference yeah
so
chad had come over to pick up his kid
now here's the thing and we're going to
get into this fact let me just get
through the the facts here but chad came
over to pick up his kid now he went over
to kyle's place of habitation and
occupation so this is the house where
kyle the guy with the gun lives and
works now he was the boyfriend of the
mom of the children though right yes so
kyle
is dating
his employee
who is the mother
yes oh yes oh this is a double bad
scenario rich so he's dating his
employee who is the mother
of chad's child so chad he's dating an
employee single mommy
yes
and chad is now remarried to a single
mommy who's in the car and one of these
videos that's recorded of this is
recorded by the single mom that chad is
remarried to so both of them are
remarried to single moms right do we eat
so do we by the way know what kind of
business um this guy was running out of
this house over here so they call him a
landman
right
now
i don't know exactly what that qualifies
as in texas maybe if there's some texans
out there shout out to my texans what a
landman means exactly whether you're
just taking care um i belie landsman
l-a-n-d-s-m-a-n
the definition on
webster is a person who lives on the
land especially
yeah like a farmer because i could have
sworn her chickens or something clucking
in the background when she was filming
right yeah i think rancher would be
appropriate okay all right
so he's a rancher texas guy right
and
the video plays out where chad shows up
and he is yelling at actually no before
that
sorry before he's uh before it looked
like he was having a conversation with
the kid's mom about where where the kid
was it was 3 15 and she said something
along the lines if i heard it correctly
that
he's not he's not here but i wanted to
spend more time with him and he's like
well it's 3 15 it's my time you want to
spend more time you know you spend it
with him on your time right yes so so he
comes in and he's yelling about the 315
he's three hours late you know at this
point so three hours late at this point
meaning it was around 6 15 at this time
when this is about 6 15 at the time of
the incident right
now kyle is initially outside on his
porch and he tells chad hey get off my
property right
like leave
and chad says i'm not going anywhere so
at that point kyle very calmly
turns around goes inside
about 30 seconds later in that whole 30
seconds chad has continued to berate the
mom he's attacking the mom he's saying
that he's going to subpoena everybody
he's going to bring him to court he's
got police that are coming to the mom's
parents house i mean just threatening
them with court process but also did the
child live at that house like was that a
residence slash business or
um the child was not at that house the
child was actually somewhere else we
don't know whether it was for sure at
the mother's house at her mother's house
okay that's the assumption but the child
was not there okay
so
the at the end of the day you know him
being there he wasn't going to get the
child because the child was not there
so
after about 30 seconds of chad yelling
at the mother the single mom and
berating her now she's standing off to
the side just kind of
you know coming up with excuses
and
kyle comes back out with a gun
and as soon as chad sees kyle with the
gun he gets up in his face
he goes
then to the infamous photo nipple to
nipple you know nipple the shoulder
right gets up in his face and he says
you know something along the lines of
you know if you're gonna bring it out
you better [ __ ] use it or i'm gonna
take it and use it on you right so he
threatens to use the gun on him
now uh at that point
kyle fires a warning shot now to be very
clear this is something that's
unambiguous in law in any state there's
no such thing as a warning shot guys you
don't fire warning shots like we're not
in the military here this isn't like you
know that we're scaring off some taliban
right this is and it wasn't up in the
air it looked like it was at his feet
right into the porch right he fired it
at his feet into the porch yeah right
so at that point when he fires the round
uh chad begins to grab the gun right he
goes for the gun um
and there's kind of some shoving
and the result is is that kyle is shoved
off the porch
which is relevant under texas law
because there's certain provisions that
relate to defensive property and your
porch your front porch is legally
considered part of what's called the
curtilage or a heavily used area of your
house which is considered part of your
habitation part of your home so it's as
if it's almost as if chad threw him
through the bedroom window right yeah
it took take you from inside your house
to out that's actually relevant analysis
undertaking he went back a few feet like
i would say what a good six feet
yeah oh yeah he threw him a good
distance yeah and then the whole you
know thing after that is that he's
thrown off the porch and within about a
second
kyle lines up a shot shoots him and he's
dead shoots him twice and he's twice
and chad is dead right and then proceeds
to afterwards talk to
the
girl who's dating chad who was filming
it from her angle and said i told you
not to come i told them to leave this
and that you know they have a
conversation but the real the legal
question has been is it justifies it not
justified i took the position that it's
more lawful but awful right like under
texas law i think it was uh lawful but
like morally ethically yeah i mean okay
shouldn't have probably shot the guy
right and
both parties were in the wrong here but
um i think that's a self-defense
analysis
what i wanted to come to you was is that
there's a lot of issues in here for
family law and one thing i got really
worked up on really really worked up on
is chad is here and he's talking about
the court process he's talking about
subpoenaing people he's talking about
the police but he's there physically
himself
trying to get the kid
that's something we call in the united
states we call that self-help right
self-help which is you are trying to go
in and enforce this court order yourself
so one thing that's that's not permitted
in the united states generally i mean i
haven't found a jurisdiction that is if
there's any american lawyers out there
that know it please message me andrew
esquire live at gmail.com or drop a
comment on my channel i haven't found
one that allows you to go and get the
kid if the mom is late with the kid
right call that you call the police you
go to the court you do something but you
don't go and get them yourself
so
i think starting out there's a massive
family law issue there's a glaring
family law issue like right up front is
that you have to use the court process
you can never go and try to use the
court order that says here's the
parenting plan
you know
drop off at 9 00 a.m in the morning and
pick up at 3 15 p.m you can't say okay
they're late let me bust down the door
come in someone's house and get the kid
because they're late
right
how old was a kid by the way do you know
uh i'll have to look into it i know that
those facts are somewhere i believe the
kid is a is
i believe that he was like four or six
years old young
so
andrew and i were talking before we went
live if you guys can let us know in the
comments do you guys know what caliber
that is because we're thinking it's
either 22 or a 9 mil
it's very difficult to tell
it's yeah it's it's very quiet like when
you listen to the footage
it
it doesn't give like it's not like it's
definitely not a two two three it's not
a 45 i own a 45 it's not that loud i
mean it's
like i was surprised to see him like i
thought it was actually a uh
like a bb gun when i heard it go off in
the video the first time i was like oh
there's no way that like you know he's
hurt because i saw him go down and then
he wasn't moving i'm like you know hang
on a second like what's going on here
uh eric says it's a 223 here which i
don't think it was because i've i've
shot two two threes and they're and
they're really loud it's way louder than
that if it's an ar and two two three you
would hear it yeah um aaron says it's a
nine mil but i don't know
that a 22 would like is it possible for
a guy to drop and not move with two
shots from 22. it's possible is it
likely no
but it's impossible i mean yes it's
possible right chad chad faust in the
comments says a 9 mil rifle it's pretty
rare right
they sell 9-mil rifles for sure
i know they do because they sell them in
canada they're they're semi-automatics
and they're non-restricted
yeah um but anyway oh it says it says
here in the comments it was a ruger nine
mil takedown okay so there you go
oh oh actually that makes a lot of sense
actually a 9 mil would make sense a 22
doesn't make too much sense but anyway
so
so from the so from the self-defense
perspective you're saying he was in the
right he was in the right to defend
himself there this is the lawyer split
so let me let me get into it here so
some lawyers
go frame by frame and say because he
waited a little bit because there's kind
of a pause he kind of even though he was
thrown he took a second to line it up
yeah they're saying that uh that's
unjustified so there's lawyers out there
that'll say you know there's this whole
law tube thing now you know a lot of
lawyers out there some lawyers will say
hey it's unjustified right under the law
my position and i think the position
that most lawyers that read texas law
and understand texas law and have gone
into it i'm not a texas lawyer but i'm
just a lawyer who can read right um is
that under texas law it's justified
the other thing is is that this is the
big fact of this case is that the family
of chad reed the guy who died right they
released this video in order to try to
push the prosecutor to file charges this
is in lubbock texas the prosecutor
hasn't filed charges now one thing one
thing people are saying is they haven't
filed charges because no jury is going
to convict even if this was wrong under
texas law people in lubbock generally
and you know i've had a lot of people
reach out from texas and say yeah this
is behavior that yeah may not look right
it's white trash but
it's known that if you go on someone's
property in texas you know you might get
shot so a jury you know is very pro-2a
they're not going to convict on this and
i have a personal opinion that we should
not be going with frame by frame shots
to justify whether something is good or
a bad a good or bad shoot that's my
personal opinion there are some court
cases that back that up that say that
frame by frame analysis is not the way
we need to break things down because
humans don't react on a frame by frame
basis that's my personal opinion right
and i think it's backed up by law
but there's lawyers i'm not saying
there's not lawyers that will argue
something completely different because
there's lawyers that'll argue a
different position
you